we have dylan here with us dylan let's
bring you up here what's going on man
how's it going guys thanks for having me
on of course all right let's start off
first uh just kind of introducing you to
everyone uh you work at bitcoin magazine
explain a little bit about what you do
there and kind of what you're personally
interested in terms of bitcoin and macro
environment yeah so um i work at bitcoin
magazine um and i lead off their their
premium markets products so um we cover
it's called the deep dive and we cover
global macro economics on-chain
analytics uh and bitcoin derivative
markets um and really just kind of
combining like the the day-to-day
week-to-week month-to-month moves and in
the bitcoin markets or just financial
markets more broadly um oh you know and
combine that with this you know 10-year
um or like really this this kind of
monetization process of bitcoin um and
combining you know both of those views
like keeping that that sort of you know
zoomed out view as well as just kind of
giving some context you know about
what's happening and why yeah and i
think that's part of what is uh so
fascinating about the way that you cover
this is you always keep the macro
environment in mind as you look at the
bitcoin market so we've got a bunch of
charts that we're going to run through
here uh let's start first with the major
central bank's total assets as they
continue to rise and help us understand
just kind of contextually like why is
this chart important and what does it
really tell you as you uh look at it
yeah so i mean there's there's a couple
of things like one we have this this new
technology right we have bitcoin and and
so many people are trying to figure this
out and and there's a lot of noise in
like the so-called you know crypto space
right we we all know this but but really
i think what's happening and what's
forcing people to adopt this technology
this monetary technology is we're kind
of at the end of this long-term debt
cycle and most people don't really um
understand this especially if they're
you know not studying macroeconomics or
you know have a have a like uh in-depth
you know history of of monetary assets
and and debt cycles right um but you
know starting in in 08 and in 2020 um we
kind of hit the zero lower bound um and
so central banks kind of ran out of
their their you know main option their
firepower which is interest rate policy
and so
you know what they went to is
quantitative easing it's essentially
just stuffing a bunch of cash in in the
bond market or really i mean
simplify it as printing money right um
but it's really just just lowering the
discount rate of of uh or the cost of
capital everywhere on the planet and so
these are all you know the global major
central banks and what this is just
showing is that they're they're trying
to keep the system glued together
but it's it's you know it's it's
cracking it's tracking at the seams and
so um this is you know actively forcing
people into bitcoin or or just seek uh
shelter elsewhere
and so when we look at the total assets
obviously every major central bank just
absolutely took off in 2020 for obvious
reasons but also in the united states
we've got this debt chart that shows a
very similar uh type of growth there at
the end in in 2020 so explain what's
going on here
yeah so this is is looking at um just
like total debt to gdp um non-financial
financial um and and right now total
debt to gdp is at 400 percent and so uh
my good buddy greg foss um he was on
your show he likes to always talk about
how it's a it's a mathematical certainty
that that fiat will debase because of
basically this chart uh with that the
gdp at 400 percent um given that all
debt has to be repaid plus interest um
unless the economy is growing at 12 15
a year in real terms then then we're in
a debt spiral and there's really no way
out um unless it's default which is
politically not feasible or to basically
debase the currency and so that's what
that's you know that's the game we're
playing and really a lot of people get
you know get upset with the puppets of
the game but it's it's more systematic
than that it's not about trump or biden
or powell or whoever you you want to you
know call shots at and and i get it i do
it too sometimes um but it's really it's
systematic um we're in a debt spiral and
and mathematically there's no way out of
this um except to continue printing and
um attempting to kick the can down the
road but more and more people are waking
up and saying i don't want to play this
game yeah i think that's a great way to
describe it uh we've got a chart here of
the real 10-year treasury bond yield
describe uh what's going on with the
10-year yield but also what the
relationship between the 10-year yield
and inflation is
yeah so um
the fed or like the government's way of
measuring inflation i believe is kind of
flawed and i think most people that are
paying attention do as well but just for
the sake of the argument we'll we'll use
it um it's you know there's pc or cpi
but it's basically just consumer price
inflation um and we're indexing that
against uh what a you know a treasury
bond could get you what a lot of people
in financial markets you know they use
as their risk-free rate um then what
you're looking at is essentially in this
chart when you break that zero lower
bound the cost of capital is negative
right so
when you're evaluating stocks real
estate um any any asset um
when the cost of capital is negative how
what's the fair value and the answer is
uh it doesn't compute it breaks um so if
you're holding a bond or if you're
sitting on a you know 60 40 portfolio if
you're you know in your pension or your
your 401k you're you're losing uh in
real terms and even if nominally you're
you're making out okay um you're
basically getting pillaged if you're if
you're holding bonds or a lot of these
financial assets because the cost of
capital is so distorted and that's
because it's a it's a centrally planned
market and so
i think these are like the the broad
macro trends here um and this is why you
know i think bitcoin would be important
regardless um and you know satoshi
literally uh released bitcoin because of
these problems i think he chose to
release bitcoin kind of strategically
but
um this is why bitcoin is especially so
important
and when we look at this idea of global
aggregate negative yielding debt uh it
just
is nuts right uh to see that now there's
about 14 trillion dollars total of this
how does this fit into the macro picture
yeah so this is kind of similar to the
past charts but basically you know a lot
of people like to call bitcoin a bubble
it's i think it's about 900 billion
today in total market cap but just for
context there's there's 14 trillion
dollars or i think this was from last
month but around 14 15 trillion dollars
of debt today that is guaranteed to lose
money it's people signing up uh giving a
hundred dollars and to receive 99 back i
mean that's simplified but essentially
that's what's going on there's 14
trillion dollars uh into that in that
bucket so uh when you when you're
calling bitcoin a bubble um this is this
new global monetary asset that no one
can mess with um i think
i think you really need some context
here about just how how big of an
everything bubble there is
in this this great monetary experiment
that central banks are conducting um
with global fiat currencies everywhere
we've never seen anything like it um you
know bitcoin at 900 billion is is an
absolute drop in the bucket and so you
know like think about 14 trillion
dollars it's it's something that you
know a million millions is a trillion um
you know just for some context it's
mind-boggling um and so yeah bitcoin is
extremely cheap
now when we think about a potential
solution uh i think most people who are
watching this think bitcoin uh could
serve as a a solution or a part of the
solution uh and we look at this chart
here of bitcoin hash rate uh and you
so eloquently put uh it's going up
forever laura maybe describe the it's
going up forever laura uh joke first and
then we can talk about the chart
yeah so that's uh i stole that from
michael saylor um and he had a did an
interview with laura um i for your last
name but laura she's talking about the
price larson yeah uh talking about the
price but uh in this case i'm talking
about the hash rate and essentially um
you know for for those who are not aware
hash rate is essentially it's just this
this you know darwinistic capitalistic
competition uh to mine bitcoin and and
this is in log scale so if you're
looking at you know at this start it's
it's going up in factors of 10 or i'm
sorry 100 no 10. um and so you know if
in linear terms it's it's it's looks
absolutely ridiculous it looks like it
just it's hockey sticking up
but what this is showing is that you
know the the competition to sell energy
to the bitcoin network um and you know
and basically all or mostly wasted
energy or underutilized energy right um
this is this free market thing there's
no one being coerced into mining bitcoin
and often time the energy that the cost
is is zero or negative right like these
oil producers are are literally you know
they have to pay because they're they're
emitting this uh methane in the
atmosphere and so bitcoin mining is a
solution to hey i'm gonna turn this
wasted energy into
into global money uh global
decentralized money and so you know what
what this is is you're seeing just this
this new monetary asset um born and the
energy cost is what the free market is
is willing to pay to secure this
monetary network and so um you know hash
rate it's something that is it's not
something that's like easy to explain to
someone that's just you know falling
down the the bitcoin uh rabbit hole or
the path but um it's one of the most
important aspects related to the hash
rate is this idea of mining difficulty
and kind of this every two weeks there's
an adjustment to the network based on
how much computing power is on there
we've got a chart that shows that actual
mining difficulty describe kind of how
you think about this and you know is it
one of the most beautifully designed uh
technical systems in the world
yeah um so so mining difficulty is
essentially um you know as more as the
price of bitcoin rises or think about
any commodity right when when a
commodity becomes more valuable gold oil
copper silver there's a larger economic
incentive to go produce that thing
naturally um that's just that's supply
and demand um but with bitcoin
difficulty um
there's over two week periods or
technically two every 2016 blocks but
you know for the sake of this every two
weeks um difficulty adjusts upwards or
downwards depending on how much hash
rate has fallen or risen so if if the
price of bitcoin is ripping and there's
this huge economic incentive to go
produce more of it just like say say if
the price of gold was was increasing um
you know the price of gold doubled well
all of these people are going to go try
to go mine gold but with bitcoin
difficulty adjusts to make it
incrementally that much harder to
produce the thing and so um it's
essentially it's
the the difficulty adjustment um
continues to kind of ratchet up
production costs as more and more energy
expenditure and people
want to go produce this thing or mine it
and so um if you could i actually
arranged the charts in a little bit of a
different order but if you could go down
to the the energy cost chart and i would
sue that it's uh two things down um i
think this is one of the most beautiful
things um this is this is uh by charles
uh charles edwards at capril investments
um he kind of put an estimate for the
bitcoin energy value using inputs like
hash rate um and um you know basic
estimates but what this shows right so
if you're just looking at 2021 the price
tanked
a bunch of miners were basically you
know for political reasons were kicked
out of china and what happened to the
energy value the energy value tanked
well difficulty ratcheted downwards
multiple times that at one point there
was a third negative 29 difficulty
adjustment and what did that do it
increased the economic incentive to go
mine bitcoin to go sell your energy to
the bitcoin network so
energy in this chart walk us through
real quick what uh everyone's looking at
here so what the green the blue and the
red what exactly are they looking at so
that everyone can uh make sure they're
paying attention
yeah so so the green is is that is the
hash rate it's not that's above um and
the blue is the the bitcoin price right
yeah and so the red is using uh various
inputs such as such hash rate as well as
some assumptions but it's basically
giving you a production cost um how much
miners are basically paying um for every
one bitcoin to produce one bitcoin and
so right now that's about you know
twenty four thousand um in may that was
about fourteen thousand but but say
right you know tomorrow the price of
bitcoin tanks you know minus fifty
percent like happened in march of 2021
or march of 2020 there's a huge
liquidity crisis you know now all of a
sudden it's not economical to mine
bitcoin well what happens miner is
unplugged hash rate plummets well two
weeks from now difficulty is gonna
downwards adjust and it's gonna
incentivize all these miners to come
back and secure the network into mine
then to mine bitcoin again and it's
going to lower that production cost and
it's going to limit that that cell
pressure on the market and so it's just
kind of this beautiful almost like it's
an engineering discovery almost i would
say not even an invention um
satoshi discovered bitcoin as this
decentralized monetary network that runs
just on economic incentives and nothing
else and and it's you know when you when
you dig into it it's one of the most you
know beautiful engineering
machines ever so when we go and we look
at this chart around the liquid and
illiquid supply we've had uh will i know
you and will are very close and uh and
talk almost daily from what i understand
uh we've had him talking a bunch about
this illiquid supply and the supply
shocks uh the chart that you've got here
around the liquid and illiquid supply
explain kind of how you look at this and
what are you looking for in the chart as
you look at it on a daily basis
yeah so um you know most of this you
know most of these charts are kind of
covering like you know broad trends um
so this is the bitcoin liquid and liquid
supply and so the total supply of
bitcoin is i think it's like 18.8
billion
but over time what you see is an
increasingly large um you know amount of
bitcoin is becoming e-liquid it's
basically being locked away and not
hitting the market again that free float
despite the issuance um kind of
increasing um or the amount of bitcoin
in circulation increasing while while
the issuance on a percentage basis is
decreasing um that free float of bitcoin
available to the market continues to
kind of to chip away and especially
since march of 2020 we've seen you know
that liquid supply hockey stick upwards
when you're looking at like in a ratio
sense so over time what's the trend
right there's manipulated cost of
capital globally everybody and more and
more people are kind of waking up to say
hey this game's rigged i don't want to
play this anymore and here we have this
monetary asset that no one controls that
no one can debase that no one can
manipulate
that is just just on economic incentives
having people adopt it having
institutions adopted having nation
states adopted and so um this is just
basic supply and demand there's less and
less bitcoin that are you know hitting
the market uh every single day as you
have more and more people kind of
porting this this new asset saying i
don't want to sell for dollars ever like
i i don't have an incentive to to ever
sell right um and i think more and more
people like the michael sailors of the
world the billionaires of the world and
even just like the average you know the
average pleb or someone in in nigeria
right this is the global phenomenon
they're saying hey i just i just want to
store my value in this thing and so you
know that liquid supply is just kind of
showing showing this trend and showing
really people just waking up to this
when you look at the realize cap versus
the market cap uh how
bullish does this make you feel when you
actually see uh just the constant um
long-term trend of appreciation
yeah so i think uh realized price is
something that i really like to look at
because
when you're talking about you know
market cap or um or just the price price
can get bit at the margin really easily
but because we have this transparent
ledger right we have the bitcoin network
the bitcoin blockchain has has a ledger
of every you know every coin in
existence and when was the last time it
moved right so satoshi's coins were
which he mined back in back in the early
days they never moved in this metric
they're worth zero and coins that you
know were acquired in in april and
haven't moved since are worth about 60
000 per coin and so when you have you
have this realized cap which is like
basically the price paid for every
single coin you can kind of think of it
like that and over time i think um you
know the day-to-day volatility of the
btc usd price it's volatile and it whips
up and down and there's derivatives and
all this but when you're looking at
realized price it's essentially you can
it's like a more pure you know view of
the monetization process of this network
it's like hey the value of every coin
the value of this entire network
continues to tick up and up and up and
up and it's basically going up forever
um and so you know i i love to look at
realized cap as more of like a realized
price it's like kind of a fair value of
bitcoin i mean very rarely do you see
the price dip under that
how old are you
i'm 20. you're 20.
when you think about you and your
friends
explain my brother here is 24. uh 25 now
25 25 25. uh and we talk a lot about the
psychological difference of how
20 24 25 year olds think about financial
markets than uh the older generation
even me at 33 i'm kind of in the middle
of some of those folks
how do you think about
equities bonds crypto bitcoin versus
anything else like are you and all of
your friends all in on bitcoin or do
they have diversified portfolios like
how do you guys think through uh
investing
yeah so um i mean i had kind of quite
the the orange pill moment i would say
over the last couple years um and i've i
think i've gotten most of my friends
there as well but um i kind of think of
it like you know going back to the
manipulated cost of capital and legacy
finance um that there's just no way that
i'm ever going to buy bond at least at
least in today's environment it's just
you know there's there's just no way in
hell i'm never gonna fund the us
government for one percent a year in
nominal terms um when you're thinking
about equities there's also because of
this broken manipulated cost of capital
you're looking at sky-high p e ratios
all-time high corporate debt to gdp i
just think um from a risk reward
standpoint it's not too attractive and
honestly i i think i firmly believe that
over the next 10 years equities will
will rip in nominal terms i think um
they'll do very well uh but when you're
when you're looking at this on a real
basis i think they they might they might
not do too great especially when you're
when you're calculating the opportunity
costs uh in bitcoin terms because um i
mean if you if you couldn't tell i have
kind of i've come to this uh conclusion
or i have this thesis that that the
risk-free rate of everything the
opportunity cost of everything is
bitcoin um and you know people will say
like are you kidding me it drew down 50
in a couple months but i'm not thinking
on that time frame i'm thinking um you
know years decades and so i know i know
one thing for sure is that um the cost
of producing bitcoin will continue to go
up forever essentially um because of the
economic incentives and because of
basically how this protocol works um the
havings the difficulty adjustment you
know everything we've covered and so
when i think about how do i want to
allocate my my wealth how do i want to
save my time and energy into the future
um with bitcoin priced under a trillion
dollars um there's basically no other
place that i would think about
allocating capital at the moment
and i think diversification um in in
this sense is not something that that
i'm uh really too too interested in um i
mean i i do own some bitcoin related
equities with you know a few basis
points in my portfolio but for the most
part stacking straight to cold storage
and and you know that's it because you
know i can handle a 50 drawdown my
volatility at 20 years old is not
something i'm too concerned with um you
know it's a different story for someone
that's 65 and and you know needs to
needs to you know draw from that capital
every day but that's just not the case
for me so you know stacking stats and
and just chilling
what i think is so fascinating about
this is one i agree with you and think
that the investment strategy is
incredibly compelling given the macro
environment the asset itself and then
kind of your age risk profile and just
the long time horizon uh but it's no
different than some of the timeless
investing advice that others have heard
so like warren buffett for example talks
all the time about if you buy a great
asset the best time to sell is never
right just hold it literally forever uh
and so uh stacking sats may not be the
same vernacular that he would use uh a
digital decentralized currency may not
be the thing he's interested in but if
it ends up in hindsight being a great
asset and people buy it and they hold it
forever it's no different than that
timeless investment advice that he's
been telling his shareholders and kind
of the public markets forever right
yeah i mean
in a warren buffett style approach like
the the markets are overpriced um and
what i'm what i'm using as my you know
as my currency or my my savings so so
i'm not investing at the moment i'm just
i'm just simply saving um because
because you know i'll wait for the
market to correct uh in bitcoin terms
you know you know when looking at
everything um look at any chart over the
last five years or the last three years
uh in bitcoin terms and i think uh
that's that's the truth that's what's
occurring and obviously um you're not
going to see a 200 percent compounded
annual growth rate of like forever
that's not that's just not sustainable
but i think um you know bitcoin is going
to see this decade at least 100x you
know appreciation maybe maybe a little
less maybe a little more but um we're
just getting started with this thing um
you know in terms of global adoption if
you look at global wealth it's it's so
it's extremely early and you know you
know i respect people that that can can
make it trading in and out every day um
but ultimately that's just something
that um i for the most part stay away
from and i just you know i'm going to
produce value and i'm going to store
that value and what i think
is going to protect the best i've got my
brother john here with me john what
questions you got yeah thanks for doing
this dylan um i love how you talk about
your 20 years old so you can withstand
the volatility and look for that future
growth but a lot of our followers are
also similar to you as uh the younger
demographic and everything can you talk
about your joint your journey to bitcoin
and how you found it and then how you
found your um and how you go about
working at bitcoin magazine
yeah um totally honestly part of my
journey was uh basically like podcasts
like this and just like the free
education that's available online um
you know i i went to college for one
year studied business economics but i
dropped out because i was learning more
on twitter
and reading books that people
recommended and so i think for anyone
that's kind of interested in this space
but more broadly you know um in the in
the you know digital economy um it's you
don't need a degree you don't need
like the credentialism of the past um
and there's so many ways to just kind of
make it out there today on the internet
um and to learn and to reach out to
people um you know like i i learned a
lot about bitcoin from watching the and
listening to the pump podcast while i
worked a day job right so um and like
you know various other ones but um it
was something i stumbled upon bitcoin
late high school while i was just trying
to figure out investing
and i just logged onto twitter and just
read what i thought smart people had to
say about it and so um that was more
valuable for me than listening to my to
my boomer professor over over zoom call
when they sent us some from kobit so you
know it was a no-brainer for me like hey
like i'm just gonna drop out and and i
uh i just worked a regular job for for
like six six months and uh you know got
a dm basically for uh for a job
opportunity which was you know maybe a
stroke alone maybe not but you know it
turned into something
something that i hope will last
nice so is it true that bitcoin made you
drop out of college
yeah yeah i for sure um i i mean i
tweeted about it and told my friends and
stuff like hey like i'm dropping out and
they're like just to work a job to stack
sass and like what's sats and why are
you dropping out like what are you crazy
um and like i honestly did it like that
i read i read a couple books that kind
of melted my brain like like the
sovereign individual i read and then
prices tomorrow by jeff booth um
basically like how the internet was
basically putting the cost of of
education and learning things to zero um
and that you know the credentialism of
the industrial age was dissipating with
the internet and so for me i was like
okay why am i studying finance and
economics uh learning keynesian
economics stuff i don't believe like
they're telling me hey inflation's two
percent and i was like no it's not like
yeah cpi says so and it was like that
was the answer i was like okay well i
don't think this is too valuable for me
so um yeah i just it was something like
all right i'm gonna drop um this is and
i got a lot of pushback from it um
initially my parents were a little
skeptical but now they're i think
they're fully orange killed and they're
stacking themselves and and you know
they agree with my decision now but um
it definitely was was not like the
traditional path per se
you you may not know that i used to say
this i'm gonna go ahead and say it i
think we're safe now the virus is
spreading that's what happens it is uh
basically like bitcoin used to be
described as this mind virus right like
once you learn about it you just can't
stop thinking about it you can't start
stop seeing the world in a different way
then you start to tell people and
explain it and it just spreads through a
a group of people in terms of the
education and the knowledge um and kind
of that that red pill that orange pill
uh type thing talk a little bit about
you you mentioned uh kind of like not
getting the formal education and the
keynesian economics and and i actually
think it's a really interesting point
that most older people uh probably don't
think uh from this perspective but if
you go to college and they teach you
something that either was true about the
world in the past but no longer is true
or two is a way to look at the world
that uh you don't agree with in some
weird way not only are you wasting your
time or money but on top of that you're
actually having information put into
your brain that ends up being inaccurate
and therefore uh could be incredibly
detrimental and so dropping out in some
weird way uh is a better way to pursue
knowledge than actually staying there
and getting that information right
yeah totally i mean they were they were
teaching me they were they were bringing
up you know textbooks from i don't even
know when the 70s or 80s and they're
saying hey this is the phillips curve
and this is inflation and this is
employment and they have this
relationship and i was like no they
don't look at that like i mean look at
the data and and it was like it was just
weird things like that it was just like
you know that was anecdotal but it was
like
you know maybe if i was an engineer or
some or something or i needed to go to
school it would be different but i was
studying like finance and economics and
and i was i was literally listening to
podcasts more than i was that i was
attending in classes and doing homework
and so i was like all right screw this
like and i dropped out and i literally
picked up a manual labor job it's like
it wasn't too fun but i listened to i
literally listened to eight hours of
bitcoin podcast today for like six seven
months um and i got i think i got the
best education in my life like it turned
into a legit job opportunity i get to
hang on twitter all day and write about
bitcoin and financial markets um you
know it's it's something that like and
that's completely self-taught over the
internet and like i'm not not like
bragging or anything i'm just like
trying to say that it's you know the
cost of a lot of this information um and
access to it and you have some of the
smart people in the world sharing their
thoughts for free on these platforms
like
it that's something that you know
college i don't think i don't think can
keep up with right like i was i was
sitting at home and in march april may
after they sent everyone home for covid
and i was i was paying to to have these
boomers on a zoom call explain things to
me that i knew factually were just
incorrect um and so you know there's
there's i think this is a gradual change
but i think we're more of like the at
the suddenly point of things for sure
what was going on in the economic or
finance classes in college like did they
have any clue about bitcoin did you ever
ask them about bitcoin were they just
dismissive of it like what was going on
yeah i did i did ask a couple guys a
couple of my economics professors um i
shared like some some of the
stuff from plan b like stock to flow
and i did ask a couple of my computer uh
science professors i was like hey like
what do you think about this and i got a
business call from from a blockchain uh
company which you know
say what you want about blockchain uh
but i didn't really think they they
understood what was occurring right it
was like oh yeah blockchain technology
is very interesting and um without
realizing that um i don't even like
blockchain to be honest i i prefer time
chain uh when talking about bitcoin like
you know satoshi solved the byzantines
general's problem and so i think like
the arab world goes very very deep with
bitcoin and what it solves and and how
big um you know the the of a problem
bitcoin solves it's literally the total
addressable market for bitcoin is the
biggest in the world and so you know i
don't think any of my professors grasped
that um it was something that took me
uh months or years even um of just like
intense intense studying intense
learning obsessive uh learning right um
the virus is literally spreading um and
so yeah i think that it was something
that they didn't really grasp at all
which was just why it was another reason
to kind of leave and just pursue
something else what do you think about
other non-bitcoin crypto assets are you
interested in any of that do you think
they have any viability how do you look
at kind of the non-bitcoin part of the
industry
yeah um i don't i don't own any um other
cryptos um i and it's not because i'm
not willing to look into them i actually
have done a lot of research to try to
understand ethereum um you know any any
other smart contract thing platform nfts
i've i've done my digging um and
ultimately
what i've kind of come to the conclusion
of is that proof of work and and what
satoshi kind of you know airdropped on
the world
proof-of-work basically linked the
digital and the physical realm um and
it's this zero to one invention um and
so you know and and it's the biggest you
know it's also the biggest problem in
the world uh which is which is basically
um the money's broken and so you know
that with basically bitcoin is this the
first and only really thermodynamically
secured monetary network in the sense
that um you have this this link of this
this ledger is essentially proof of of
energy expenditure um and and it's this
immutable thing that nobody can change
or alter and so um i think the genies
out of the bottle in that sense and that
um that's that's something that is
extremely compelling for me like in
terms of crypto um nfts if you want to
speculate on on all you know all these
other things proof of stake that's great
and i think it's more of like a computer
science experiment slash next startup
kind of thing but i think fundamentally
bitcoin is here and then crypto
anything else is separate right um and
then it's tough because there's so much
nuance there
in terms of decentralization as a
spectrum like you know how decentralized
is is enough um all these things but
ultimately i think it's it's clear to me
at least um there's bitcoin and then
there's
cryptos and whatever else you want to
build and again like i'm gary gensler
coming in and saying like these are
securities like you know let the free
market do its work like i i don't want
any of these things to be shut down or
killed or whatever but ultimately i
think um you know 20 years from now
bitcoin is a sure bet and and some
people might think i'm crazy for saying
that but i think from a game theoretic
standpoint bitcoin's won it's it's
already won um but all these other
things you know build frac build fast
and break things great like you know go
ahead but i'm not interested in really
speculating i just want to save uh save
my value and and have it be a sure bet
so
for sure uh and then through the end of
this year obviously i think most of the
data that you uh post on twitter or talk
about shows that we're still in a bull
market what's your kind of price
thoughts or price predictions for the
end of 2021
yeah um i think you know something i'm
watching closely is the evergrand thing
um you know there's been a lot of talk
about that recently on twitter but um
there's there's potential for there you
know kind of be some sort of spillover
contagion effects um with that but
ultimately the supply dynamics i mean i
do talk with with will every day and i'm
looking at that same data um it's
extremely bullish like you know the most
bullish i've ever been
and so you know these supply dynamics it
doesn't lie and a lot of times
derivatives will whip saw price back and
forth but i think ultimately um we're
i'm pretty confident in all-time highs
breaking by 2021 and at that point it's
off to the races bitcoin trades
reflexively um you know once all-time
highs are broken or um you know
essentially people just stop selling
price gets gets bid
uh really hard at the margin and you're
gonna have a ton of new capital kind of
flowing in um there's a lot of talk
behind the scenes of big money um you
know buying buying in this range and so
you know i think that's only going to
you know kind of pick up from here and i
think you know once 60 64k 65k is broken
it's off to the races and so you know
i'm pretty confident in that occurring
uh in 2021 um and you know depending on
how fast a rip to 100k is is in the
carts um and so price predictions are
kind of hard but you know supply
dynamics are extremely bullish and
especially if china or you know the fed
broadly kind of respond to any sort of
credit contagion or you know anything
happening in the legacy markets you know
that's just rocket fuel for bitcoin and
when you think about this are you a
subscriber to this like super cycle
theory that once we break the all-time
high we go up you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars or is it something
where uh maybe will is in more of the
thought process of like 180 185 000
based on some of the models he's looking
at like how severe is that reflexivity
once we break the all-time highs in your
opinion
yeah i mean i i'm a little in both camps
so i mean one is like i'm just going to
be looking at the data but i think
there's a real chance and i don't know
if it happens in 2022 or 2024 but at
some point um bitcoin's success
is going to just be so so obvious and
the narrative is not going to be between
you know with us just kind of niche uh
you know econ nerds or you know um
hardcore bitcoiners like libertarian
kind of thing i think that's even
shifted recently but um it's going to be
oh my god the legacy financial world
it's like you know i'm sitting on a
trillion dollar bond tranche and i'm
getting i'm getting a negative yield
right like these guys that are basically
still locked in these they can't get
bitcoin exposure yet um but if an etf
comes as it just gets more mainstreamed
intertwined with you know the legacy
system companies like naidig and all
this you know they're they're going to
unlock trillions and trillions of
dollars capital to access the bitcoin
markets and and the you know the most
bullish aspect is that when you're
looking at a liquid supply when you're
just looking at the free flow of this
thing that's trading every single day
you know about 14 15 million bitcoin
aren't available to be sold and like
people like me like i'm not like i don't
have a 20 200 000 price target where i'm
selling my all my bitcoin i'm just like
i might you know sell a few basis points
or you know like you know obviously
money's you know meant to be spent but
the the reality is like my price target
for bitcoin is infinity like i don't
plan on i'll spend bitcoin when when uh
you know it's legal tender and i don't
pay taxes on it
and so like you know i think that's
that's the reality here and you're gonna
have tens of trillions of dollars
chasing um you know a few million
bitcoin and so you know do the math on
that but ultimately um i think at some
point over the next five to ten years
maybe i don't i don't think it gets that
far the dollar price becomes somewhat
irrelevant um as trust is lost um we've
just we've just pushed you know they've
kicked the can so so far um and you know
what happens next time the legacy
markets crash well the feds the feds use
all its ammo and it's gonna just you
know it's gonna it's gonna they're gonna
blow the load again and it's it's it's
gonna get i think it's gonna get kind of
crazy so um you know super cycle not not
entirely sure i think you know naturally
there's gonna be boom and busts um 50
drawdowns are here to stay especially
with how over-indebted the the legacy
system is right um you know you're going
to see these these huge cascades just
because of how how much debt is in the
system um and then how much impairment
that causes with you know with with the
legacy system fiat money uh money's
created through lending but it's also
destroyed through debt uh debt default
right so so when that happens you're
going to see just massive drawdowns and
equities real estate bitcoin like um
that's just where we are in the you know
in the system and so they're gonna have
to reinflate it all and that's you know
that's when bitcoin trades to seven
figures
i uh i tend to think that you're more
right than wrong here uh before i let
you go uh
where can we send people what do you
have forty five point nine 000 followers
so for sure we're going to get you to 46
000. i don't know how high we can go
we've been uh been telling folks to go
follow you here in the comments other
than following you on twitter i'll put
the link in the description right now uh
where else do you want us to uh send
people
yeah so you can find um i do a the deep
dive with bitcoin magazine so that's a
daily newsletter um we're covering on
kind of most of the stuff we've talked
about if you check that out it's like go
to bitcoin magazine i think it's at the
top right um it's uh we got a special
discount code for today's show it's uh
it's 10 bucks a month for six months
discount code pomp so just so you can
give it a try um i mean i think i'm i'm
really happy with the work we put out we
put out about 20 20 pieces a week that
are pretty in-depth research um covering
kind of the you know more of the like in
the weeds of the on chain and derivative
market stuff um so you know those those
price predictions you were asking me
about you know we're not giving straight
up trading signals but um you know
covering probabilities and various
things that could happen in the market
um so yeah that's where you can find me
twitter i hang out a lot um you know in
my dms if you have any questions
all right so before i let you go we're
gonna take a couple of questions from
the uh the audience real quick uh so if
anyone's got questions go ahead and
leave them in the uh in the chat here
and john's gonna pick one or two of them
for us to ask but uh dylan you obviously
can't see the chat at the moment but you
have a new nickname according to the
audience they are calling you dylan
saylor
which
and they keep saying that uh you dropped
your crown and they are posting the uh
the king crown in here so they i think
they very much uh are in uh enjoying the
uh the uh uh content um all right so
questions uh here john anything that you
see
uh do you think that's good one person
asked earlier on the show was are you
looking at anything besides bitcoin for
investments uh real estate like any
different kind of assets or is it just
uh bitcoin
yeah so um i think at this at this stage
in my life right like being 20 years old
um just trying to accumulate as much
capital as possible diversification like
doesn't really make sense because i'm
doing things in like basically bitcoin
denomination so um when i'm when i'm
evaluating equities like right so i love
i think amazon is a fantastic business
just just for example um but i don't
think amazon is worth 42 million bitcoin
or whatever right like and so just just
viewing uh any sort of investment
through that lens um is something that i
i try to do um i think amazon you know
the nasdaq real estate more broadly like
what whatever kind of legacy investment
you're talking about it's going to go up
and it's going to go up a lot in dollar
terms over the next decade i'm pretty
confident that due to just the the debt
dynamics um but if your baseline is
dollars you're doing great if your
baseline is bitcoin well i think you're
gonna you're gonna probably get killed
um and so you know i'll buy i'll buy
amazon stock when it's when the market
cap is less than you know 500 000
bitcoin or whatever it is right um just
just kind of doing things through a
bitcoin denomination is is what i do and
that's why you know that's what leads me
to basically have
i have over 100 of my net worth in
bitcoin um you know because of because
of liabilities
so
a couple of people are asking what would
make you bearish or what would make you
sell bitcoin uh in terms of uh things
happening in the market
uh what would make me bearish um is
basically over like over a long period
of time not something just like china
but hash rate
decreasing um significantly and staying
i'm staying there whether um and i don't
see how that happens but it would have
to be you know maybe there's this
another proof of work network that um
one you know doesn't have the liquidity
of bitcoin doesn't have the network
effect all these things which leads me
to be supremely confident that bitcoin
has already won but if hashrate you know
left the network um to go somewhere else
um then that would really make me kind
of rethink the thesis because ultimately
you know bitcoin is the most secure
proof of work network and and because of
the network effects that come off of
that the security the immutability of
the protocol like all these things um
that that leaves me supremely confident
uh in in you know my holdings my savings
and so um the dollar price like you know
if even if bitcoin went to 15k you know
because of the ever grand spillover and
legacy markets blew up like i'm buying
hand over fist and i'm going to go to
every bank i can and try to get a loan
right like there's there's not there's
not a dollar volatility move that makes
me sell uh what makes me sell is is some
fundamental flaw in the protocol that
you know millions of people looking at
this thing every day haven't found yet
but that would make me rethink my thesis
you know no dollar volatility in the
market so i'm gonna ask you to clarify
this because uh i don't think people
caught this when i asked you uh how much
of your
portfolios in bitcoin you said over 100
uh which is not usually an answer people
here so explain what you mean by that
yeah um i've taken out um i've basically
gotten my hands on any sort of uh credit
i could in 2020 um around
april may uh june time frame um a lot of
like i actually got um you know not
financial advice guys
bad terms and conditions uh
um i took out like um because i'm you
know i was 18 19 at the time like i
wasn't available to get like you know
you know a billion dollars at zero like
michael saylor uh but i could get a lot
of i got a lot of zero percent uh credit
cards for 18 months so i stacked i
stacked my butt off uh in that time
frame and so i still am still carrying
that debt because honestly again not
financial advice but 15 12 apr whatever
it is
i'm pretty confident uh in uh in bitcoin
outperforming that so uh when the
benchmark is bitcoin uh fiat denominated
liabilities like i have a i have a cash
flow i work i have a you know i get a
paycheck like it's not something that
i'm i'm too worried about so yeah if you
know if you're looking at a net worth
basis i have i have over 100 in in
bitcoin
you understand that that is insane by
boomer standards and uh it's par for the
course in uh in bitcoin world
yeah i i i told people that uh back in
2020 even today and people some people
look at me like i have three heads and
i'm like no man it's prudent and then
and i like they think i'm joking i'm
like no it's not it's it's prudent for
me um and so yeah i mean again not
financial advice but um when you're like
why if you're just looking at like say
michael saylor right or or anybody
that's taking on dollar liabilities um
you know michael saylor bitcoin has to
like when he's borrowing six percent at
500 bill 500 million to buy a 37k well
what's six percent kager what's what's
bitcoin have to be at in 2027 like 50k
maybe um for him to break even and so
like you know obviously everyone's
situation is different but if you can
service the debt if you can service this
um the coupon the interest payment then
um i i don't think that's that's risky
um you know don't don't over leverage
yourself and have it all blow up because
you don't want to become a forest seller
um but again yeah when you're when
you're evaluating things with this
artificial cost of capital um against
this monetizing digital bearer asset um
you know the math is is i think is on
your side yeah it's absolutely
incredible uh in some weird way i'm
proud of you good job uh not financial
advice but uh seems to be uh working out
for you all right um everyone go follow
dylan on twitter i'll put his uh twitter
handle one more time in the chat make
sure you go follow them hopefully we can
get them to let's see have we already uh
oh yeah we already pumped you over 46
thousand you're uh you're well on your
way uh the other thing is john what do
we think dylan's follower account is on
twitter by the end of the year end of
the year okay
more than double look at he he's like
i'll take that off
i'll take that that's all right john's
at 50k are you are you and dylan going
to race to 100
we'll see what bitcoin does
it's on john what do you got you got 50
yeah i got 50. oh donald at 46.
so he's got bitcoin behind him john will
start tweeting a lot about bitcoin if
all of a sudden that uh send me some
charts
all right buddy listen thank you so much
for doing this uh we appreciate it we'll
definitely do it again in the future and
uh and keep going man you're doing a
great job and i think people really
enjoyed it
thanks for having me on guys a lot of
fun all right see you later what's up
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you ten dollars in
bitcoin for free it's that simple head
on over to sofi.com to get started today
thanks so much for watching and i hope
you come back and watch more the best
business show tomorrow
[Music]
you